et justement l'invité politique du 191
ce soir c'est Noël Mamère le candidat
des vertes bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
effectivement aller beaucoup plus loin
que que Lionel Jospin dans cette affaire
du hachich vous êtes pour une
légalisation contrôlée du cannabis ça
veut dire quoi oui parce qu'il faut
sortir de l'hypocrisie et des tabou tout
ce qu'on vient d'entendre c'est quand
même de la grande tartufferie un jeune
sur deux consomme régulièrement ou ou de
manière sporadique du du cannabis et
beaucoup d'adultes en consomme aussi
toute cette prohibition est réglée par
une loi qui date de 1970 donc on
finalement en faisant comme si ne rien
se passait on est en train de de
cautionner l'idée qu'on peut
transgresser la loi et moi je la réalité
jusqu'où alors bah jusqu'au fait que le
cannabis c'est beaucoup moins dangereux
que l'alcool et que le tabac que le
tabac il est distribué par l'État que le
tabac il fait des cancers dont nous
payons les dégâts que l'alcool au volant
fait ça crée la violence routière et
donc le cannabis j'ai dit pas que c'est
une substance banale nous ce que nous
voulons les vers c'est sortir des tabous
et dire qu'il faut réglementer et
contrôler les drogues douces
l'utilisation des drogues dou mais ça
veut dire que vous êtes par exemple vous
imaginez des plantations de cannabis en
France contrôlées par l'État et pourquoi
pas il y a bien aujourd'hui des
plantations de chambres qui servent à
faire de l'isolation dans les bâtiments
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi on ne
pourrait pas cultiver du cannabis comme
on cultive du tabac simplement il faut
le contrôler il faut interdire son achat
et son usage en dessous de 16 ans il
faut interdire la revente et il faut
aussi permettre les contrôles comme on
le fait pour l'alcool avant de prendre
le volant vous savez aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus on n plus au 19e siècle j' je
suis désolé pour Monsieur Chevenement et
quelques autres je trouve Madame
Bachelot très en retrait par rapport à
un certain nombre de propositions
qu'elle a eu le courage de faire
notamment sur le Pax et sur la
reconnaissance des homosexuels en terme
de société et je ne vois pas pourquoi on
laisse le cannabis encore enfermé dans
le territoire des tabou alors on vous a
je le dis alors que je n'ai jamais fumé
un pétard mais c'est pas parce qu'on a
jamais fumé un pétard qu'on ne peut pas
reconnaître l'existence d'un phénomène
qui de toute façon n'est pas dangereux
pour pour la jeunesse vous pensez que
c'est pas dangereux pour la jeunesse
elle sera sera encore moins le jour où
on légalisera c'estàdire qu'on interdira
le trafic et que l'on ne permettra plus
d'acheter la paix sociale comme on est
en train de le faire aujourd'hui en
laissant dans des bonslieux des
économies parallèles se constituer c'est
ça qui est le plus dangereux alors on
vous a reproché dernièrement à propos du
du nucléaire de de développer une
polémique pour mieux exister dans dans
la campagne électorale vous n'avez tout
de même pas découvert j'imagine que que
Lionel Jospin n'était pas pour le
démantellement du nucléaire vous l'avez
vous le savez depuis 5 ans est-ce que
les idées de de Lionel JP devrait être
aussi vitrifié qu'après une catastrophe
nucléaire il peut changer il sait depuis
97 date à laquelle nous avons accepté de
passer un accord de gouvernement et de
majorité que les vers français comme
l'ensemble des vers européens et comme
de nombreux pays européens sont pour une
sortie progressive du nucléaire nous
sommes aujourd'hui il faut que quand
même ceux qui nous écoutent le sachent
nous sommes aujourd'hui le seul pays qui
est l'otage du lobby des des
nucléocrates de l'df vous savez les
mêmes qui vous disent aujourd'hui que
c'est complètement sûr alors qu'il y a
il y a à peu près
500 500 incidents par an c'est-à-dire à
peu près 19 par toutes les heures pas
des incident grave tout de même et ben
il y a des fissures il y a des des
problèmes comme celui qu'on a connu avec
la centrale nucléaire de Brou
Saint-Louis au moment de la grande
tempête de 1999 il y a donc de
véritables menaces et une véritable
vulnérabilité ce que je dis c'est qu'on
peut faire exactement comme on fait les
Allemands ou comme l'ont fait les Belges
ou comme le font d'autres c'est-à-dire
geler le nucléaire ou en sortir en 20 ou
25 pour se donner le temps de la
reconversion des personnels pour se
donner le temps du démantelllement des
centrales et surtout pour s'engager dans
une vraie politique de d'énergie
d'économie d'énergie et d'efficacité
énergétique donc par exemple le geste
qu'on pourrait demander à Lionel juspin
mais ça dépend pas de moi ça dépend
beaucoup des électeur et et de la force
qui nous donneront au soir du premier
tour c'est de dire on on arrête la
production de plutonium à la Hague vous
voyez je vous ai amené une épingle voyz
cette épingle est toute petite vraiment
je sais pas si on la voit sur l'écran
mais la plus plus sur le côté voilà là
on la voit bien bon mais dans
l'équivalent plutonium de cette épingle
ça peut tous nous irradier et tous nous
faire mourir sur ce studio il faut
savoir que du plutonium comme ça il y en
a 70 tonnes qui sont entreposé à la
Hague c'est-à-dire à peu près 60 fois la
puissance de Tchernobyl donc il faut pas
nous dire qu'aujourd'hui le nucléaire
c'est quelque chose de sûr donc en plus
tous les pays européens sont en train de
sortir du nucléaire donc nous allons
rester le dernier pays qu'il sera otage
de cette forme de d'énergie alors lional
Jospin il vous répond là ce soir dit
l'avenir du nucléaire ça ne se discute
pas entre deux parties c'est un choix
fondamental pour le pays je n'envisage
pas effectivement une sortie du
nucléaire mais ce type de sision ne
pourrait être prise que par les Français
tous ensemble mais que n'a-t-il attendu
pendant les 5 ans pour saisir les
Français de cette occasion moi je lui
propose qu'on organise un référendum ou
qu'il reprenne notre proposition qui est
dans mon programme d'une loi
d'initiative citoyenne quand 500000
Français veulent voir un sujet examiné
par le Parlement le Parlement est obligé
de le faire alors prenons l'exemple de
la sortie parti progressive du nucléaire
et de la diversité de notre énergie je
vous rappelle que dans un sondage qui
date de l'an dernier 51 % de Français se
sont déjà prononcé pour une sortie
progressive du nucléaire pour l'abandon
du nucléaire au profit de la diversité
de notre alimentation en énergie Noël ma
mère lorsque Jacques Chirac lors de son
déplacement au mont-sain-michel a
dénoncé les verres sectaires est-ce que
vous êtes sentivisé non pas du tout
parce que Monsieur Chirac il est quand
même il nous amuse il peut nous dire en
1996 qu'il ne faut pas interdire les
farines animal à l'ensemble du bétail il
peut nous dire le lundi qu' pour est
qu'il est pour une agriculture
écologiquement responsable et le mardi
nous dire que les OGM c'est formidable
puis monsieur Chirac il a quand même été
il est quand même au pouvoir depuis 35
ans il était déjà ministre du temps de
bregenieief il a été ministre de
l'Agriculture à plusieurs reprises et
jamais il n'a remis en cause la
politique agricole commune qui soutient
les exportations qui tue les les
agricultures des pays du tirmonde et
puis qui nous empoisonne regardez ce qui
se passe en Bretagne en Bretagne on ne
peut même plus boire un verre d'eau tiré
au robinet puisque le la Bretagne a été
sinistrée par l'agriculture intensive
dernière question en forme de sourire
j'ai lu que si vous ne dépassiez pas 5 %
vous souhaitiez redevenir journaliste
oui c'est un clin d'œil que j'ai fait
parce que je suis convaincu que je vous
allez dans ce cas revenir à cette place
et pourquoi pas non mais c'est mon
métier le journalisme aujourd'hui je
suis dans une fonction qui est la
fonction politique je dirais sous forme
de boutade pour revenir sur un mot qui
m'avaitu quelques colibet dans la
fonction politique je suis révocable par
les électeurs mais je suis convaincu que
nous pouvons avec notre mobil et avec
les sujets que nous abordons devant les
Français dépasser le seuil fatidique des
des 5 % parce que je je sais que les
Français aujourd'hui ont envie
d'améliorer la qualité de leur vie de
leur alimentation de leur santé de leur
travail qu'ils savent que les verres
peuvent y contribuer merci Noël Mamère
d'avoir été l'invité du 1920 pour